we're driving around MIT campus today in
this little bit of rain in a Tesla of
instrumented with six cameras plus other
senses all going into a single board
computer the reason we're doing that is
we're going to give you a demo of driver
gaze classification one of the things
we're interested in our group at the MIT
age lab is developing systems for driver
state detection so there is the first
part is the perception control and
planning which comes from the external
sensors video cameras radar sometimes
lidar and then there's inward-facing
sensors like the cameras we have in here
that detect the state of the driver this
is an important component because the
car that's driving itself needs to know
when the driver is able to take control
back and vice versa and now is a
visualization of some of the
synchronized data we're capturing both
for real-time detection and
post-processing analysis top left is the
video of the face bottom left is the
video of the hands lap and the
instrument cluster bottom middle is the
cropped video of the center stock
display bottom right is the fisheye
video of the instrument cluster and the
top right is a video of the forward
roadway and then there are two things
being detected in the top middle is the
visualization of the facial landmarks
used in the gaze classification and the
bottom right are annotations of the
instrument cluster video showing the
status of the auto pilot based on the
automatically detected auto pilot icon
we can think of these two detection x'
as classifying the state of the human
and the state of the machine and allows
us to study the handover of control from
the human to the machine and back one of
the key novel aspects of our approach is
instead of looking at gaze estimation as
a geometric problem we treated it as a
supervised learning problem and
classifying gaze into one of six regions
of road rearview mirror left right
center stack and instrument cluster
this approach allows us to use large
semi-automatically annotated datasets to
generalize over the edge cases that pop
up in the wild and then in addition to
the data on the can network
there's the automated detection of
automation State from the instrument
cluster this combination of detecting
human state and machine State allows us
to study the interaction between the two
you